[Music]
this story could not be real you if you
were making a film someone would say
okay that's too no no it's not possible
it's it's not real it's not possible
make it real I have no inconfidence in
saying and explain what really happened
and if I have to go to jail because I
have said something which I should not
say someone tell
[Music]
me and I went at
home and I say to my wife This is the
End wake up to my sons I
say
uh today is the
end the stup case against me and against
my wife I think this is a a process to
make fear that lost everything I start
from
zero sooner than later they will try to
indict us for whatever money laundering
child
abuse ER drug trafficking or whatever
they will invent it and they will try it
because at the end is not a matter of
result it a it's a matter of destroying
the person and with in that way
destroying the line of
defense I agree with the rule of law and
I also agree with the basic terms of uh
democracy but they don't so it's quite
strange no to protect in the name of
democracy the heritage of the
dictatorship with no separation of
powers no respect or freedom for the
truth and you never think you never
believe that you will be the target of a
conspiracy or that you will be in the
middle of of a story like this one I
mean this is something that you see in
the
news
people is getting fed up and we get to a
point that will explode Andor will pay
the price unfortunately will pay the
price the young people especially that
my father wasn't bad that he had a
problem because the government sold our
country to
[Music]
America Our Story begins in Andor a
micro country with a land mass of 181
square miles consisting of a couple of
valleys in the Pyrenees Mountains
landlocked between France and Spain with
a total population of less than 80,000
people you can seek the entire
population of andor's capital city
inside Madison Square Garden if you've
never heard of the country of Andor
until now you are not alone it's not
uncommon for an uran resident entering
the United States to be stopped by
passport control and question under the
accusation of carrying a fake passport
from a fake country the quality of life
in Endora is one of the highest in the
world no poverty no crime and ranked in
the top five safest countries the source
of its healthy GDP comes from 8 million
tourists visiting annually for its
skiing duty-free shopping and its
banking system andur first gained its
independence in the year
1278 and for the next 700 years Andora
was ruled by medieval feudal overlords
until it finally created an executive
legislative and judicial branch of
government when it first established its
constitution in
[Music]
while Andor is the world's only
co-principal its 1993 Constitution also
added democratically elected
presidents
foras and unlike other countries that
utilized Offshore Banking as a Haven to
hide their stolen wealth during World
War II andor's Flagship Bank Was Born
This Way Offshore Banking simply refers
to the deposit of funds by a company or
individual in a bank that is located
outside of their National residence it's
not always a vacation destination like
the Cayman Islands Bermuda or the
British Virgin Islands Offshore Banking
is everywhere with some of the most
accessible Offshore Banking located
right inside the United States this
simple fact of opening a bank account
offshore doesn't imply that you are
doing something
wrong let's take
Argentina Argentina is a country where
approximately every 10 years some way or
another one way or another the
government steals the money from its
population either by means of inflation
either by means of ceasing the money
they they find they find their way they
already created for that so if you're in
Argentina what you do is just to first
to have dollars not pesos and second
just to hide your wealth under your
mattress if you can or if you can afford
it just to go somewhere else in the
world and store your money there however
most of the world's Fortune 500
companies store trillions of dollars of
their profits offshore to avoid paying
taxes 293 Fortune 500 companies with
offshore earnings collectively owe
752 billion in federal taxes that's $52
billion more than the bank bailout of
2008 celebrities businessmen world
leaders and politicians from both sides
of the aisles say safely store their
wealth in Offshore Banking to avoid
paying taxes by opening up fake shell
companies to hide their money America's
IRS is powerless over this so they audit
the poor instead given the inherent
secrecy and anonymity of shell companies
terrorist funding drug and human
trafficking profits and all sorts of
criminal money laundering is rampant
every day open the open the newspaper
and you will see all this news about
criminal networks all that Mone most of
it is is passing through the financial
system and the most a bank can do is
just apply certain controls which are
standardized so in that regard the banks
the most they can do is just to try to
minimize the damage the problem is that
the trend not in many countries in the
last 10 years from the authorities the
police has been to point to the to the
banks and to the individuals working at
those Banks and they are making them
responsible of what the clients do you
can fight you can make your best you can
have a very big team and very but you
cannot avoid money lering it's not
possible it's like the po po you have to
avoid criminals and they say okay we
have a police here we have the police we
don't have criminals no you have the
police and you have criminals you have
compliance department and you have money
lering if a client comes to make a
deposit at your bank with a briefcase
with $1 million stained with blood well
maybe
maybe there are some leading indicators
here that may point that something is
wrong but honestly it's completely
uncontrolled in the wake of the Attacks
of September the 11th America introduced
the Patriot Act and within it also
introduced something called a section
311 to promote the prevention detection
and prosecution of international moneya
laundering and financing of terrorism
section 311 of the USA Patriot Act
grants the director of finsen The
Authority upon finding that reasonable
grounds exist for concluding that a
foreign jurisdiction foreign financial
institution class of transactions or
type of account is of primary money
laundering concern to require domestic
financial institutions and financial
agencies to take certain special
measures to address the primary moneya
laundering concern finsen May impose one
or more of these special measures in
order to protect the US Financial system
from these threats finsen stands for the
US Department of treasury's Financial
crimes enforcement Network a section 311
notice issued by vinsen consists of
nothing more than a standard press
release section 311 was designed to deal
with a very severe problem that could
lead to a need for emergency action and
it's being used for anything but it's a
tool um and it's being used you know for
other political or regulatory goals and
there's really no there's no recourse
while the September 11th attacks cost
the terrorists a half a million dollar
to execute in 2012 HSBC an offshore Bank
originating in Hong Kong was caught and
openly admitted to assisting the caloa
drug cartel and terrorist organization
in Mexico to launder at least $881
million enough to pay for
1,762 September 11th attack finsen never
issued a section 311 against HSBC and
HSBC is still operating business as
usual in 2017 when Denmark's offshore
Bank dansa bank was caught and admitted
to laundering $230 billion of criminal
money for the Russian State the
equivalent of 460,000 September 11th
attacks fin sen never issued a section
311 against dansa Bank either in fact no
large Commercial Bank of primary moneya
laundering concern has ever had a
section 311 issued against them some of
the banks are really making a business
line out of doing really bad business or
their procedures and policies you could
drive a truck through nobody goes to
jail and these banks are so large that
they're not going to get shut down and
so what you have is a um a situation
where only the little guys in the little
places where it's not going to cause a
disruptive effect systemwide and so in
that sense the biggest wrongdoers have
the most
insulation and the the smallest
wrongdoers or those that aren't even
doing wrong at all are going to be
victims without any meaningful redress
and if you look at who has been gone
after with Section 311 notice is they
are almost always smaller banks in
smaller places to
begin I am Joan fudo I did my studies in
Barcelona about the the economics I
stayed for quite 30 years in laaa which
now is Kaa bank and finally I came to
Andora to bank a Privada Andora BPA
which uh was a bank who was trying to
grow up because I was advertised when I
came to Andora that this country was
near to lose its condition of uh tax
Heaven more sooner than later because of
the pressure of Spain and France against
tax heavens and uh in fact immediately
we bought a bank in Spain which was Bank
of Madrid and we had clear from the
first moment that our future was in the
on sh system not in the offshore one it
has its days near to close and then Bank
Madrid was the jail of the crown and it
was a a a history of success until the
moment that the bum came on March 10th
2015 the United States treasury's finsen
issued a section 311 press release
against
BPA I didn't know who were Vincent until
that
moment and the the the three or four
person that were in the room we didn't
know anything about Fin I have no idea
what finsen was to be honest I knew what
was fin but they don't for me that was a
a normal day uh so I just walked into
the bank went to my to the office at
12:00 the enough called me and say Santi
you have to come to
enough to our offices and then Santi
appears he said we need to go to theaf I
said enough it's a regulator I mean you
deal with the regulator and he said we
need to go to enough
Shan and myself and we stay there
waiting waiting waiting and they didn't
explain anything and we started to to
talk up obviously Among Us saying what's
going on and they they said we we have
no idea of what's going on nobody tell
us and they say that we cannot go out
they didn't allow us to live which was
quite surprising that they know uh s he
said I need to go he's diabetic so he
said I need to go out my my father is a
diabetic person so he need his insulin
and my mom told me I just went to the to
the place where all the people of the
bank work she came actually we I
remember I said to him do you have a
phone charger at spare at home yes pleas
please because we were running out of
batteries with all the messages call I
received other messages from other
people saying the war in the street is
that the BPA is bankrupt other people
was telling me the bank has liquidity
problems I mean I said that that's
impossible so I mean I discarded those
and then we start to look at internet
the notice is issued we saw that notice
in our cell phones it surprised us for
me it was incredible it's like a shock
because they are talking about some
things that are not real to be honest
the first reaction uh that we had was of
of we relaxed because we saw what was on
the no this makes no sense the the
notice is is full full of
misrepresentations I will say of the of
the actual facts and also the the notice
has outdated uh information and we were
relaxed I mean like okay we we we can we
can handle this it's not that we have I
don't know uh an account from Osama bin
ladin and we didn't know about that that
will be a huge problem so they issued a
section 311 notice it was under the
patrion ACT there was no suggestion of
any terrorism whatever andor's president
Antony Marti immediately appeared on
television
they were not simply just an enduring
bank they were a Spanish bank so they
had to subject all of their policies and
procedures to the
scrutiny of a European Union regulator
which had to meet all European Union Reg
regulations and they hired top
accounting firms to do the work and make
sure that they were running it properly
and fully in accordance with the indor
and Regulatory system but also with
global standards on money laundering 99%
of the world's top 1,000 companies are
regularly audited by at least one of the
world's top four major accounting firms
KPMG deoe price Waterhouse Coopers and
Ernst and Young based on the intern
ational anti-money laundering
regulations established by the United
Nations article 52 prevention and
detection of transfers of proceeds of
crime KPMG conducted independent annual
anti-money laundering audits of BPA from
2008 to 2012 overlapping with deoe
independently auditing BPA in 2007 and
2013 followed by a 2014 audit completed
by andora's own Financial intelligence
unit all three of these independent
audits demonstrated zero money
laundering activity during the same time
frame that America's section 311 alleges
BPA was engaging in moneya laundering
March 11th 2015 24 hours after America's
section 311 against BPA Maria kosan the
director of anaf andora's financial
regulator goes on National Television
assuring the people of Andor that
everything is
fine
meanwhile while Maria kosan is speaking
to the uran people bpa's small sister
branch in Panama is ordered liquidated
BPA Panama's liquidation and audit was
headed by Jamie d gambo in my direct
communication with Mr D Gamboa he
confirmed his role and confirmed an
independent 2-year audit concluding that
no moneya laundering transactions were
detected the following morning on March
12th 48 hours after America's section
311 the andoran government and a nap
headed by Maria kosan suddenly
contradict everything they had said in
the previous 48 hours and ordered all
BPA customer accounts Frozen allowing
each customer a maximum withdrawal of
€2500 per week causing Mass protests in
andur with bpa's customers demanding
full access to their accounts the
general manager of
Ina was the auditor from working in
KPMG and was the
auditor of BPA from
2008 until
2011 and when finish it in cap BMG she
went to be the general manager of in so
she was the
auditor from all the activity of BPA
Spanish Bank bank of Madrid has filed
for bankruptcy customers rushed to empty
their accounts bpa's banko Madrid
simultaneously goes bankrupt in the
Spanish media members of the government
uh went to official TV saying that bank
Madrid was a under machine and crimes
everywhere now there are uh
sentences on the court and state that
there was no lering at all in Bank of
Madrid but the thing is done the order
was to liquidate it also on March 12th
the andoran government and a Naf seiz
full control of BPA resulting in the
majority of bpa's management fired and
sent home until further notice I
remember that every morning I woke up
and I told my father okay how hard it's
going to be today so from scale from 1
to 10 how hard is going to be today I
say
uh today is the end he was he was fired
but not not just fired but he didn't no
he was he wasn't able to work as an
economist more March 13th 2015 72 hours
hours after America's section 311 John
Paul Miguel pratts bpa's CEO is arrested
and spends the next 2 years in prison
which is the maximum time allowed to be
held in prison under enduring law
without the enduring police requiring
any burden of proof that an actual crime
has been committed I never imagine that
could happen in two years that's not
normal what is there that is allowing
them to to arrest him what do they have
and he ended up that they didn't have
anything March 16th 2015 6 days after
America's section 311 Jordi CA andor's
Minister of Finance goes on National
Television
Al the infamous Panama papers leak
revealed that Mr Jordi CA before
becoming andor's Finance Minister was
also the owner of an offshore company
this company was in the business of the
blood diamond trade Jordy sinka held
significant shares in an enduring
company called or fund a conglomerate
dedicated to gold and diamonds three
subsidiaries of this group operated in
Liberia under the bloodthirsty dictator
Charles Taylor who gave tax privileges
to one of orun subsidiaries Charles
Taylor is currently sentenced to 50
years in prison for crimes against
humanity at a special war crimes Court
in the Haag and it was proven in court
that the Civil War he waged that led to
the rape dismemberment and murder of
countless civilians was financed by the
diamond trade Jordi CA was not merely a
shareholder he also actively worked with
the or fund group ca's name appears on
this document for example as the sender
of 500,000 pettas to El [__] fana the
dictator's right-hand man involved in
that civil war with whom this enduring
company was working with to be able to
exploit the blood diamond mines in
Liberia in addition Jordi cinka had
contact through this company with
Fernando Fernandez Reda an associate of
one of the largest arms dealers in
Africa
also on March 16th Jordi cinka concludes
his National address without mentioning
that he contracted price Waterhouse
Coopers to begin auditing bpa's alleged
moneya laundering activity how the
government of Andora manage to know if
in BPA there were a lot of criminals
Contracting price waterhous price
Waterhouse is an American firm who is
one of the big four and if price
Waterhouse says it is good it is good
and if says it is bad it is bad and the
United States will accept it because
price I was there when price waterhous
came to to BBA I was there and I saw how
they work Che your knowledge have they
found anything wrong no not at all not
at
all and nothing
bad well this is not
possible here it must be something wrong
if incent says it is true finally they
had to make something and believeable
they asked
me because at at first I I thought they
were in good faith and they was in good
faith they asked me okay Isabel tell me
tell us which are the complicate
customers the
customers if you have to susp to make
any suspicious of your customers which
will be that customers and I make a list
for them and the list was the list that
they say that have the clients that has
not pass nothing else in other words
after analyzing 15 million transactions
spanning 7 years of more than 37,000
accounts price waterhous Coopers found
zero evidence of money laundering at BPA
price waterhous Coopers then asks
Isabelle bpa's compliance officer to
make a list of possible suspicious
accounts which were immediately placed
into the moneya laundering pile which
amounted to
2,165 customers or 7.4% of bpa's open
accounts amounting to
32.4% of the entire monetary value of
deposits of
BPA um what
happens the clients passed through a
crucifixion well PR hor Coopers uh came
to Andora with a lot of young economies
very
young
and make a a back work for me uh there
are nothing
worse than an incompetent with
initiative in order for Price Waterhouse
Coopers to keep their charade alive they
needed to invent reasons for these
customers to be categorized as money
launderers they accomplished this by
demanding proof of origin for each and
every penny deposited in these selected
accounts thus creating an instant demand
for endora's legal
professionals
years later you ask me about when I buy
a car are you
crazy or this 500 and what you do with
this I don't remember ah you a moneyer
if you don't not de demonstrate the
origin of the money is good you will not
get it oh but it belongs to my father
and my father is dead I don't know how
to how many account holders you
represent 1000 700 to 1,000 the two of
you
um
for
there's been no proven of any wrongdoing
no money laundering so
far
but so price waterhous Cooper's job is
now finished yes there not no uh there
are they still here 4 years later yes
they are they still working on this
today this price Waterhouse yes what are
they doing
today asking for stupid things
justifying that we are MERS in this
process everybody are
guilty until prove they are
innocent
on April 2nd 2015 23 days after
America's section 311 a new law is
passed in andur and Arab is formed with
the purpose of managing the processes of
resolution of banking entities with its
board of directors appointed by the
Minister of Finance Jordi CA and the
anaf directed by Maria
kasan one of the chief arits of the new
andoran law that created Arab was Xavier
espot andor's Minister of Justice at
this time who today is now the elected
president of
Andor
not
of
to
[Music]
SP
after then Minister of Justice Xavier
espot manipulated the Arab law his
family were allowed to keep all of their
cash deposits at BPA while the majority
shareholders and founders of BPA and
Bano Madrid Raymond and [__] siero
locally known as the siero brothers
watched all of their cash deposits
vanish as did many members of bpa's
General management not only only were
Xavier espot family the second largest
shareholders of BPA they are a very
wealthy family that own a chain of 70
luxury cosmetic stores across Spain and
andur Julia perfumery who were also
named in the Panama
papers Arab begins plans to create a
good bank to place what price waterhous
Coopers has deemed as legitimate assets
segregated from BPA with plans to
immediately sell the new bank once it's
set up June 17 2015 3 months after
America's section 311 Arab creates Val
Bank as its new good bank where 67.6% of
bpa's deposits are safely placed with
the remaining
32.4% being placed into what is locally
referred to as the BPA tomb 2 Days Later
andor's co-prince the prime minister of
France travels to Andora for the first
time in
history
followed in December by andor's other
c-prints from
[Music]
Spain
for
also at this time the siero brothers
began engaging in a multi-year legal
battle with the United States Treasury
and finsen even addressing the director
of finsen herself Jennifer Calvary our
view was then and still my view now that
a great Injustice was done to these
folks BPA was one of the good ones the
moment that the section 311 notice was
issued that no um had the intent and
effect of all US Banks saying we will no
longer clear your dollars and when an
International Bank can no longer clear
dollars they're done they were in
question they weren't asked they weren't
given a day to explain themselves it
just happened and overnight they were
shut down you have a chance to respond
but by the time you
respond uh you've been out of business
for a week two 2 weeks 3 weeks a month
no US Bank will deal with you and you're
finished and again you say well how can
you expropriate a bank section 311 of
the Patriot Act allows them to do it we
challenged that we said there must be
there must be some way to say no no no
you've gotten it wrong here let's get
this sorted out but of course it
behooves the treasury to run out the
clock because the longer that a bank
stays without the ability to operate the
less chance there is to reinstate it and
it goes down to the vanishing point very
quickly later on when the family owner
of the bank was going to a lawyers in
the United States trying to get Justice
from this operation
finson
exceptionally withdraw the measure and
the accusation
against bpn February 19 2016 finsen
withdraws its finding under Section 311
regarding bka Prada dandur as BPA no
longer operates in a manner that poses a
threat to the US Financial system less
than one year after issuing the notice
uh the finson withdraws the notice the
notice has been withdrawn quicker in the
whole history of fin establishing a
this is very
strange the fact was that the petition
to the court was to get the documents or
the information that have conducted
finson to take this strong decision and
the
judge said well if finsen withdraw the
measure there is no documents required
if it is withdraw there is is no
accusation no guiltiness and you can go
away yes but we are dead you had in your
hands a knife you killed me but then you
take the knife out of my body and say
well no no the the knife is here if you
die that's up to you and it was a
strategic maneuver to essentially take
away the notice that was the trigger
that gave us a right to respond and so
it it was a truly arbitrary use of power
that was unreviewable to shut down a
bank without any meaningful ability to
go forward and so we ended up where the
US government coordinated with another
country made a victim of a private bank
shut it down made it unable to uh come
back to life sold the assets for a you
know for a pittance to another a
different a US entity called JC flowers
Chris you have a history of buying cheap
Assets in crisis times uh we do try to
buy banks in times of Crisis but we have
mostly stuck to the mature markets not
the emerging markets that has its own
level of colorful risk which might be
too colorful for us April 21st 2016 13
months after America's section 311
American private Equity Firm JC flowers
purchases Val Bank uh good morning my
name is rard an economist partner of a
company called traces we were charged of
analyzing some specific uh economic
aspects of uh the the operation set up
around BPA and uh the bridge Bank
created to uh resolve I mean the the
situation at the end of today
summarizing summarizing in one of the
most convoluted confus using yet clever
displays of sheer economic gymnastics a
story that by itself deserves its own
feature documentary JC flowers purchased
Val Bank a business valued at 1119
million from the government of andur for
only 16.6 million to simplify the
details of this transaction the sale
price of valb Bank was € 29.8 million
but Jason flowers paid $3.8 million the
convertible bonds or shares of common
stock in the bank were valued at7
million but JC flowers paid 12.8 million
meaning that JC flowers acquired an
existing profitable international
business at an astounding 86% discount
what means this that well they make a
baby profit baby I mean when I when I
say they I mean JC flowers have you you
ever seen anything like this in your
career no no I am 73 years old and I I
have never seen and I even cannot
imagine something like this because the
owners the original owners of BPA lost
everything with the sell of the bank to
JY flowers and so you are spending time
and effort and money to do an autopsy
not to try and do a cure for what's
happened America's actual section 311
notice against BPA claimed that BPA had
facilitated transactions involving the
proceeds of organized crime corruption
human trafficking and fraud for the
Mexican caloa drug cartel the country of
Venezuela Russian criminal organizations
and companies in China
CH the entire scope of America's
allegation that BPA was laundering money
for the Chinese related to a Chinese
businessman named GA ping GA ping
immigrated from China to Spain in the
1990s and rose from a smalltime cook in
a Chinese restaurant to becoming a
BigTime multi-million Euro businessman
and art dealer he initially built his
fortune by importing Chinese leather
products into Spain and then reselling
the products for cash in 2012 more than
2 years before America's section 311 gal
ping and dozens more were arrested in
Spain in one of the biggest tax evasion
operations in Spanish history scin is
not client of Andora has never come to
Andora and we have never seen him G
Ping's only relationship to andoran
banking was through one of his high
ranking managers Raphael Pau who was
also arrested in 2012 in fact rapael Pau
had multiple bank accounts linked to
galing in Andor not just
BPA rafao he travels frequently to China
they he Buy in a factories to China and
he buy beds bags and leather and things
like that and sell them in in Barcelona
as bpa's head of liance Isabelle
requested proof that this operation was
a fully legitimate business and we start
working with GS but not too much gas
is very very common in in Andora in that
moment gal ping was committing tax fraud
in Spain by depositing cash in andoran
Banks his operation started with Raphael
payo driving with cash from Spain into
andur to deposit into his bank accounts
from there bankwire from pyo's accounts
would be sent to China to pay for more
products to be shipped back to Spain to
be sold but in 2 years the cast
makes it was something like the 2008 all
the business are really really bad and
you are like while the world was dealing
with the aftermath of the 2008 banking
crisis Rafael Payard do began expanding
this operation by granting large amounts
of cash from ging's business to any one
in Spain who needed quick cash on hand
in exchange for an immediate bankwire
reimbursement between bank accounts in
Andora the economy was in crisis so what
a lot of people did said okay I have
this half a million euros offshore I
need that money right now just to pay s
and to pay staff and since the Spanish
police knew this they were at the border
just controlling basically every car and
that's why they appreciated so much disc
system we are not so comfortable we are
getting something like 15 for transfit
and we are assuming a lot of risk of the
G we have both Bank of Madrid BPA was
aware they couldn't continue working
with Spanish customers who were
intentionally evading Spanish taxes
while BPA was simultaneously operating a
bank on Spanish soil and for this reason
it's because we stopped the operation in
2011 2011 Vincent note March
2015 incredible when the note appears
you say this this this is preistoria
this is past very very past to summarize
BPA opens an account for Raphael Payard
Jo in 2008 BPA fires him as a client and
closes his bank account in 2011 more
than one year later Raphael payo is
arrested alongside gal ping for tax
fraud in 2012 3 years before America's
section 311 but that's not the
interesting part shortly after BPA fired
Raphael Payard do as a client in 2011
gal ping asked him to set up a fake
meeting with one of gal Ping's Partners
Yang Jun Yang luring two BPA employees
into Yang's office in Madrid pretending
to see about opening a new bank account
at BPA then trying to trick BPA
employees into admitting something gal
ping could use against them all while a
hidden camera was recording the entire
meeting oblivious to what was happening
BPA refused to open a bank account for
Mr Yang gal Pang tried to use this tape
in a failed extortion attempt against
BPA by threatening to go to the media
with this tape if BPA didn't take
Raphael pallardo back as their client
rafao is very afid of the Chinese and
they record him and then Rafa came to
Andora and asked the commercial okay we
have a record that say that so you are
not going going to stop us I say okay
forget about it if we decide to stop you
we are going to stop you for us it's not
a problem go to where are you going with
this we didn't make any any drama of it
this video recorded in 2011 was
discovered on a USB drive by Spanish
police during their massive galing tax
evasion arrests in
2012 the video was publicized after 2015
March 17th 2015 one one week after
America's section 311 an edited version
of G Ping's failed extortion video
suddenly appears on National Spanish
media as proof that BPA was laundering
money for the
Chinese
remember when bpa's CEO John pal Miguel
pratz was arrested just 72 hours after
America's section 311 and held in prison
for two years without charges well the
reason for John Pal's arrest was because
Spanish police threw Raphael Payard do
in the back of a Spanish police car
drove him across the border to andur and
forced Raphael to give false testimony
in front of an enduring judge against
John pal Miguel pratz leading to his
arrest
rapael Poo's only physical evidence
against John pal Miguel Pratt was one of
Raphael's own handwritten cash for wire
transfer agendas with the partial name
John pal Raphael later admits that
Spanish police forced him to falsify his
testimony yet johnp Miguel pretz remains
in enduring custody for 2 years anyway
he continues to stand by his story
claiming I have been a puppet of the
prosecutor and the court who have used
me to justify the intervention of the
bank but in the same agenda figures the
name of some other persons in some other
banks in Andora which should be also in
jail if the case is the
same and uh are not and never have been
according to reports from the andoran
police department scores of people were
taking advantage of rapael Poo's cash
for wire transfer service ranging from
famed porno actor nacho Vidal to the
family of andor's Minister of Justice
Xavier espot andor's 20 19 elected
president and head of
[Music]
government and in our
case everybody is processed someone's in
prison and in the other case nothing
happen and the case does not
Advance wh why not on one hand the
police is saying the bank is hiding this
and on the other hand he's saying thank
you very much Mr bank because if it
wasn't because of your records we
wouldn't been able to cross all the
transactions it was like I I mean you
Andora had five banks at this time H
Bank credit Endora Mora Bank bank
sabadel Endora and BPA four of endora's
five banks were engaging in identical
operations for gal ping through rafhael
payo but only BPA was intervened they
did the same operation with ging exactly
the same operations exactly they always
work with Euro
never they make any transfer or BP rece
BPA receive cash in US dollar so this is
this means American authorities and
uh American correspondent Banks they
couldn't know the
existence of this
operation it means that the information
from this
client comes from
Spain America's section 311 alleging
that BPA was laundering money for the
Russians focuses on a man named Andre
patro exactly how rapael Pau was GA
Ping's Handler Mr Andre Pat was a
Handler for a former decorated Russian
army General winner of the Science and
Technology States prize for the Russian
Federation and acting CEO of a company
responsible for cleaning and repairing
all of Russia's oil pipelines Mr Victor
kenin we know that this it's a very
important person in russan has a lot of
money so he he put some money here it's
not uncommon for a man as wealthy as
Victor kenin a public figure living and
working in Russia to place their money
offshore in hopes of discouraging a
kidnapping or other potential security
risks so that was a client with a dosier
like this that was for me so clear that
that client wasn't nothing wrong Victor
canin's activity consisted of two
transfers from a bank in ltia to BPA one
in 2003 for 20 million and another in
2007 for30 million under the company
name DDC limited the money GES from his
own company I mean he a transfer from
one pocket to another pocket chase the
country nothing else we are not selling
we are not buying we are not making any
business I just have my money here and I
want to change this to another country
upon the €30 million EUR deposit in 2007
BPA contacted the Latvian bank to
confirm the standing of Victor kenin and
DDC
limited the following year BPA
commissioned croll a compliance risk and
diligence firm headquartered in New York
City to independently audit Victor kin's
activity for anti-money laundering and
Corruption Petro open an account here in
in Andora and and gets the money from
the account of Victor to the account of
petol that's all a salary for me like
compliance Andre P was not significative
January 2013 2 years before America's
section 311 against BPA Andre pet is
arrested by Spanish police for
corruption and tax evasion crimes that
are completely unrelated to Victor kenin
however more than 2 years later on March
23rd 2015 13 days after America's
section 311 against BPA the Spanish
media suddenly releases a series of
claims linking Victor Canin to Andre
Petro's criminal activities Spanish
media also claimed that two Executives
from BPA traveled to Moscow to visit
Victor kenin in person with one of those
Executives being Santiago roselo which
was true as it was santi's job as
Financial director of BPA to closely
Monitor and periodically visit a client
as big as Victor kenin the Spanish media
also reports that the other BPA
executive on this Moscow trip was PA
Llana publishing that he had been
arrested 9 months earlier by andoran
police for laundering Drug Money the
Spanish police is lying when they say
that I went to Russia the Spanish police
is lying when they say that I stayed at
Satchel is lying when they said that I
pick up my passport at the Barcelona
Airport I mean that all those are lies
two days after this was published the
law firm of Eric Lewis wrote this
Spanish newspaper requesting the removal
of these defamatory claims as well as a
retraction
proving he did not go to Russia and was
never implicated in drug money
laundering yet to this day ABC Spain has
refused to edit this article even though
they are completely aware that this
article is a humongous lie it was
coordinated Vincent issues the notice
against BPA and suddenly all these
articles about BPA about myself about
everything just is there this was
planned while Spanish police were
arresting Andre pet in January 2013
something else was being coordinated the
police called me hey hi Isel I'm the
police I have an account that has to be
locked today it was a Friday night I say
okay I'm having dinner with my with my
husband at the at the restaurant no no
no we have to lock it now say the bank
is closed it's not nothing is going to
happen to Monday no no no Isabel you
have to go to the bank and you have to
lock it right now okay bring me the the
notice to the to to the restaurant he
came to the restaurant I was having
dinner and I open the the envelope and I
see I sign and I
see Victor kikin the Russian oh my God I
remember that Customer because it was a
big customer and when the police left I
take the phone and I called Santi my
phone in when the Russian people were
clothes in jail in January
2013 my my phone was being CL T and all
my conversations were recovered during
one month I didn't know and he say hi
Santi sael here the police has come they
have lock Victor
Ki Andre P BOS STI says what but that's
not possible he's our businessman we
have everything yes I'm sure that we
have everything perfect in that account
we have nothing to to to worry because
the account is perfectly documented okay
okay bye-bye when we know this we offer
my presentation to the audien National
saying we doesn't understand what
happened with me if I can explain what
you need I come to the audal to explain
whatever you like they say no don't
worry you you are not relevant in the
case and you are not but a part of the
case this is in
2013 when in 2015 we have the
intervention of BPA Spain then decides
to resurrect this case Santi was
suddenly facing a year in jail and
€300,000 in fines if convicted the
police make the interpretation of the
conversation clearly both of them know
what's happening and they are saying
that everything is perfect because they
know that we were recording them and
they want to high that there is
something wrong that was the police
interpretation of my conversation with
Santi santi's case finally made it to
court in October 2018 only to be
immediately acquitted because there was
no case it was not appealed by the
persecutor so it's F this Absolution I
know that P has also an account in in a
bank according to andoran police reports
showing records dating as far back as
2007 Andre pet was also using andbank
for his activities with more than 3/4 of
a million EUR in deposits yet no action
has ever been taken against anbank or
its employees finsen section 311 against
BPA also claims that Andre Petro is
suspected to have links to Simeon m
levich one of the FBI's most wanted
fugitives this may be the most powerful
man you've never heard of his name is
Simon Mich the Russian mobster he has
access to so much including funding
including other criminal organizations
that he can with a telephone call affect
the global economy yet no state agency
has produced a shred of evidence to
support a link between the two men one
day something comes to me and says hey
um send uh coordinate a meeting between
the the new manager of the international
business unit and and uh Mr pet I just
sent an SMS to Petro I have never seen
him before I have never interacted with
him before and because of that SMS the
Spanish police tapped my phone while
Santi was a lead manager for bpa's
Russian clients involved in America's
section 311 Pablo was a lead manager for
bpa's Venezuelan clients involved in
America's section
[Music]
America's finsen alleges that a
money-laundering network engaged in a
wide variety of business for elit profit
connected to Venezuelan government
officials including Venezuela's public
Oil Company pavesa the owner of sitco at
the time PESA as such never sent money
to BBA and this is something that blows
my mind when they when I read their
notice of finding because you won't find
any single
transaction sent from pdva pdva to BPA
while manufacturing the story that BPA
was laundering money for the Venezuelans
the Spanish police had to get really
creative during this National Spanish
news broadcast that aired on April 7th
2015 a month after America's section 311
the audience was told that the Spanish
police had been tapping the phones of
BPA Executives while trying to follow
the Russian mafia but suddenly the
Venezuelans just happened to appear on
the scene so Spanish police started
tapping the phones related to bpa's
Venezuelan clients even though Spain's
police were tapping phones inside Andor
the Spanish police had no jurisdiction
to intervene in a case between Venezuela
and Andora and this is where America's
finsen came in Spanish police then
presented to America's finsen evidence
of moneya laundering at BPA for all the
clients mentioned in America's Section 3
11 including Venezuela thus resulting in
America shutting down BPA and banko
Madrid the first time I saw a
conversation of mine was on a newspaper
I read it and the transcription was so
wrong but the next wave was that shocked
me was when I started to hear then to
see in the in the television to to hear
my conversations during this same April
7 2015 broadcast Spanish media started
playing Pablo Lana's re-edited phone
conversations on National Television as
proof that BPA was laundering money for
the Venezuelans Pablo Llana had no idea
his phone was being recorded in
2013 until he watched and heard his own
re-edited phone conversations broadcast
live on National Spanish TV in April
2015 2 years later perfectly coinciding
with America's section 311 against BP a
it's very frustrating when they are
lying and you say I can prove that
that's not true and but you can't Pablo
immediately hired an attorney and took
this case to court in May of 2015 just
weeks after the first broadcast his
attorney presented diagrams to the court
showing how his conversations had been
highly manipulated when aired but no
retractions were ordered and the Spanish
justice system did nothing to remedy the
situation when when when I when you
you're watching when you're hearing your
conversations and you see that those
have been edited I Can't Describe I
can't find the words to describe the the
level of frustration and anger that that
generates with Venezuela there are two
types of business one with the insurance
company bpa's Venezuelan clients
consisted partly of International
Insurance brokers who shopped for
reinsurers like guy Carpenter or Lloyds
of London to ensure various National
Business in Venezuela and the other with
the China companies these clients also
broker deals to build factories in
Venezuela using Chinese technology as
well as importing wholesale vehicles
from China for retail in Venezuela it's
a commercial operative we we we get the
money in Andora from the company with
the taxes with the dedu with all the
everything publicly released andorn
court documents redacted the names of
the numerous Venezuelan clients of BPA
but they did list the other Banks they
were working with with these Banks
depositing 90% of the Venezuelan Capital
into BPA with this list of banks that
the Venezuelans had wired most of its
money to yet no Bank in this list was
ever investigated or had a section 311
placed against
them
this case was under vigilance of the
unit of financial investigation in Andor
they consider its activity suspicious
when we were asked for these clients to
get 50 million away from the bank we
advised and they immediately said no no
no block the money and then the person
in charge put it in a court and accused
these people of money laundering in
November 2012 more than 2 years before
America's section 311 the blocking of
Venezuelan assets at BPA for this
alleged money laundering went to trial
in Andor the Court's final decision was
to to lift and void this imposed block
finding no wrongdoing the general
attorney was not confident with this
decision and asked to investigate it
again this case was then escalated to a
higher enduring Court dated July of 2014
8 months before America's section 311
still without having provided sufficient
evidence of crime or money laundering
the money was finally delivered but not
all they still left some money in the
bank
they were
innocent Joseph and Tony sylvestri was
one of the local andoran attorneys
representing the Venezuelans in this
case the judge and the and the tribunal
the highest tribunal says that no proof
that Venezuelan uh make laundry money
and and freeze all the accounts after
this me and all other lawyer receive the
the payment of or service
after that uh CES the the Vincent notice
and uh talk about the Venezuelan
citizens and freeze again the accounts
with all the process anti- money
laundering of uh BPA look my account and
the account of the other lawyer and say
hey what this amount this amount comes
from the Venezuelan uh the judge on
freeze and say h okay you're a laundry
you you you make laundry morning are you
crazy is the judge who un freeze is a
judge who say there are no proof in
Andora to be a lawyer is a Prof a risky
profession this is human rights attorney
and partner of the European Center for
constitutional and human rights Gonzalo
buer who has been representing Joseph
and Tony in this case judge who released
the
money before the fining note is the same
judge is the same person the same human
being that is charging Sylvester and the
others lawyers for money laundering out
of the money that she has declared is
clean money so at the end of the day you
don't know what to do I mean you win a
case out of that case you're paid and
you end up in a wor sitution that
declined that you acquitted after that
start a case against me and against my
wife because she is co-owner of the
account I think this is a um process to
make fear to the to the
lawyers all my money in BBA all my money
of all my career was freeze everything I
lost everything I start from zero um I'm
upset together they are currently
seeking the attention of the United
Nations demonstrating massive human
rights violations within the country of
andur if you don't know how to manage a
case you indict the
lawyer that's the problem
M and finally the fourth case in
America's section 311 alleges that BPA
worked with the caloa drug cartel in
Mexico and facilit itated the transfer
of bulk cash derived from narcotics
trafficking in the United States this
would mean that the caloa drug cartel
after being cut off from HSBC in the
United States for doing this exact same
thing with no section 311 being ordered
against HSBC would now manage to somehow
transport huge amounts of cash by boat
or plane from the United States to Andor
to then deposit into BPA it's possible
that fin needs to stupid
to put this case in the in the note we
never found a single indicator whatever
nor is anyone pointed to one that had
anything to do with the caloa cartel or
anybody else and there's nothing that
even sniffs of that that's that's what
we found uh and now when we have been in
the US through all the different courts
and we arrive to the end and one of the
judges asked the prosecutor representing
fincent said well have you shown any
proofs and all she can respond is we
have issued uh a statement about this
and the judge he asks at her again uh
listen in this process at any instances
from the beginning have you shown any
proofs of the charges that you have
against BPA that has Justified the
intervention of the bank say well what
we have done is is and he gets upset and
said listen have you or have you not
shown any proofs and she has nothing to
say because he's upset already at this
point he said no you're honor that's
where we are I mean they they're
building everything based on the crimin
credibility of finsen not on evidence
because it they could have got evidence
this case will be in the US in a US
court and not in an uran Court I mean
the whole uran Judicial
System you can put it into one courtroom
in New York why did you choose this to
do it because you don't have a case was
the time of the us being very careful
and watchful of what was going on in
Venezuela you know with the Russians so
they put like the spices to make it all
tasteful and appealing to the US
government let's go for this plus this
is a small country no statistic interest
whatsoever a small bank so nobody's
really going to complain about this uh
we have a political and strategic
interest in getting along with the
Spanish they may not fully believe the
Spanish but just go along with them go
with the Flor let's make them happy and
so you've got two countries coordinating
but they're basically coordinating to
deprive in you know innocent folks from
being able to have a meaningful remedy
it's troubling it should be troubling to
everybody and and can could happen to
anyone anywhere and the banks uh are not
going to fight and the foreign
Regulators aren't going to fight they
didn't fight for their bank they they
decided that they would circle the
wagons around the other Banks and do the
US's bidding the penalty would be borne
by the
catalon in their
midst the penalty would be borne by the
midst by now you are likely asking
yourself why what would be the
motivation for Andor and Spain to
justify framing BPA for moneya
laundering intentionally destroying the
bank and countless lives in the
process it's got a name
loer that's the
reality everything that's behind this
issue is a lower it's a war with other
means which is uh
using legal tools within the legal
system to destroy D
enms in a way that appears to be legal
so they explored the the contradictions
of the law and they use the legal system
why because normally uh in in each
country the theur the the judicial
system doesn't get a contra power
counter power or or or checks and
balance and what had happened in Andor
is exactly the same they wanted to
protect the bank who was convenient for
them and they want to destroy it another
why this other bank BPA was not
convenient because because they didn't
want to play along in certain things
that were important both for andur and
also for Spain which was a campaign to
destroy the Catalan
movement for for me it was not a
surprise because we know perfectly how
the Spanish state Acts or reacts when
the Spain feels threatened by someone is
a former Empire as a former Empire made
by violence and
genocides he has no
limits and he has a sense of the power
linked to the concept of impunity it
doesn't matter if Andor is an
independent and sovereign state the
Spanish police could act inside the
Spanish state and also in Andor so for
us was not a surprise to discover the
dark side of the Spanish state is acting
against Catalan interest
Spain consists of 17 regions the most
famous being Madrid Spain's ruling
capital and Catalonia where Barcelona is
located these two regions have been in
bitter Conflict for
centuries in the 18th century Spain has
tried to eliminate katano introduce
Spanish during the administ through the
administration the public administration
and through the roads and through the
school because at this time during two
centuries it was really Catan was
forbidden in the schools during many the
time for instance the papers in Katan
were forbidden and the broadcas in Katan
was forbidden and the television at the
time of FR was forbidden the Spanish
language was first imposed on the
Catalan people nearly 300 years ago even
though most spoke only katalan
successive Spanish governments launched
decree after decree to weaken the use of
the Catalan language in 1881 it was
banned on legal documents in 1896 in
public meetings and on the telephone in
1900 in the theater in 1939 when
Francisco Franco came to power it was
banned absolutely everywhere people
caught speaking in katalan were arrested
and severely beaten speaking or even
reading a book in Catalan in public
places was considered a direct protest
against Franco's long-running fascist
regime a regime that has left Spain
second only to Cambodia for the highest
number of missing persons you had a
fascist dictator Franco in Spain you had
this fascist dictator Hitler in Germany
when that resolved there was trial there
was a conclusion to that and there was
no
conclusion anything you want to say in
that regard yes yes I yes
so was a fake the Spanish transition to
democracy was a fake because first
Franco has that in a bat as a head of a
state no Revolution no process against
fascism has uh removed Franco from power
but biology
since the death of Francisco Franco in
1975 the ghost of his fascist ideals
remain prominent in Spain to this
[Applause]
[Music]
Dayan with the continued repression of
Catalonia taking Center
[Music]
Stage ever since I was a little girl
I've been seeing these differences I
would go to the supermarket and I would
found an elder woman speaking in Spanish
with her grandchild telling them in
Spanish don't buy this this is
and I would think you are living in
Catalonia how can you say that how can
you be opposing a product that's made in
this land this has nothing to do with
politics I have traveled a lot in Spain
uh since I was a little kid and I would
find people insulting me and my sister
for speaking in Catalan with each other
they would come to us and say you are in
Spain you should speak Spanish like very
ugly situations and very uncomfortable
situations and I've been in during this
my entire
[Music]
life the first catalonian statute of
autonomy was passed by the Spanish
parliament in
1932 after Catalonia held a public Vote
or referendum with 99% of catalonians
voting in favor of this statute but 7
years later once Francisco Franco took
power this statute was a abolished
resulting in four Decades of repression
and bloodshed against the catalonian
people after Franco died in
1975 another statute of autonomy was
drafted and passed in
1979 but it granted Catalonia only
limited autonomy from 1980 to 2003
president Jordy puol dedicated his
presidency to Catalonia's right to
self-governance and gave birth to what
is known today today as the catalonian
independence movement when P stepped
down in 2003 a new government in uh
Catalonia appeared the main uh goal of
uh that new government was to develop a
new statute of autonomy for the country
I was the head of the opposition at that
time in the Catalan Parliament I was
fully involved in this uh political
operation and then I personally
negotiated with president zapatero at
that time the Spanish prime minister I
negotiated with him the statute of
autonomy and we reached an agreement and
that agreement was transformed in a
Spanish law approved in the Spanish
Parliament by an absolute majority then
that law was sent to Catalonia and in
Catalonia there was a binding referendum
and the outcome of the referendum was
74% of the yes vote so the statute of
autonomy the new statute of autonomy was
okay and uh 4 years after that in 2010
uh the uh Spanish constitutional Court
struck down the main articles of the new
statute of autonomy in Catalonia that
had been previously uh approved in a
binding referendum by uh people one of
the members of the uh judges of the
Constitutional tribunal which is the top
the one that said doesn't matter what
the people has decided doesn't matter
what the parliaments this cannot happen
came to New York because he and his wife
were very close friends to one of my
in-laws at home we had breakfast at home
I said why all this you know why don't
we try and he told me Miguel you the
catalans make
money but don't forget Spain is run from
Madrid
in 2012
2013 there were in Catalonia and in
Barcelona specifically huge
demonstrations more than 1.5 million
people in the streets asking for a
referendum and this is what I tried to
negotiate with president aoy at that
time Spanish prime minister and the
answer of President Rao was always the
same there is nothing to talk about my
position was if you look at what is
really happening in Catalonia and you
see in a Consolidated democracy that
more than 1.5 million people are in the
streets asking for a referendum your
answer is there is nothing to talk about
in November 2014 president Archer Moss
decided to hold a non-binding symbolic
referendum not an actual referendum the
equivalent of taking an opinion poll of
the catalonian population for
self-autonomy 80% of voter turnout voted
in favor of Independence back in Madrid
president Mariano Rao's government
responded by convicting president Archer
MOS of Civil Disobedience banned him
from holding public office for two years
and finded his party nearly 5 million
EUR mayor of chirona caros pjon has been
voted in as the new president of
Catalonia the move puts the northeastern
region back on the road to secession
from Spain after months of political
deadlock and waning support in his
predecessor Ur M we are a minority a
national minority in Spain we are only
16% of the Spanish population so we have
no power enough to be uh respected our
decision because we are a minority so
the only tool in the international laws
that protect minorities is the right of
selfdetermination
and the only way to achieve that is to
be independent in October 2017 president
Carles P Deon authorized a binding
referendum for Catalonia's Independence
there is a lot of people in Catalonia
who who doesn't want independence but
they want to vote and then want to
decide together with the others their
future when I saw that
day when then I see also my my regards
the day um there is only a word
hope obviously there was another word
violence police are breaking their way
into a building so it looks very clear
at this very early stage in the voting
process that Madrid is not going to let
this
[Applause]
happen
well here you can see protesters in
jerona in northeastern Catalonia facing
off against officers while demonstrators
have their hands up in a sign of
nonviolence but police apparently
started hitting them with batons well
another video from Catalonia shows
police jumping on and violently kicking
protesters as well as dragging the
activists out of a polling station
tossing peaceful voters downstairs
striking them with batons and
confiscating ballot boxes
catalans lined up to vote many paying a
high price for it now people are still
trying to vote here but we do know that
it's just two blocks away uh there was
there was another polling station
another building of the school that was
just basically raided by police
[Applause]
forces
[Music]
but that was very disappointing for me
to discover Spain has not changed I was
very sad
seeing uh the hate in the face of
Spanish
policemen they were
activists in the name of the unity of
Spain they were not worried about the
image of Spain the that the that image
uh Spain offers to the world as
authoritarian State violent State they
doesn't matter all
that was a also a day of Shame for
Spain in a day of Shame for Europe I
conducted my interview with president
puon in September 2019 in Belgium where
he remains in Exile but just 4 weeks
after my interview this happened nine
catalon leaders will spend between 9 and
13 years behind bars for their roles in
staging an independence referendum back
in 2017 the vast majority of Voters said
they were in favor of breaking from
Spain and the regional Parliament
declared Catalonia's Independence but
Weeks Later Spain nullified the
independence declaration dissolved
Catalonia's Parliament and took Direct
Control of the region Spain Supreme
Court handed down the sentences Monday
after finding the former leaders guilty
of
sedition thus triggering the worst
political crisis in Spain since the era
of Franco angry catalonians managed to
shut down Barcelona's airport and
Highway
System Madrid's repression of Catalonia
isn't just about culture it's also about
money according to a January 2020
treasury report in 2015 and 2016 alone
Catalonia contributed to Spain 33.6
billion EUR more than it
received so what does Madrid's war with
Catalonia have to do with assassinating
a private bank in Andora wait until you
get a load of this in May of 2014 10
months before America's section 311
against
BPA bpa's CEO John pal Miguel pratz is
visited by the atache to the Spanish
Embassy in andur celestino baroso John
pal Miguel highly suspicious of this
meeting decided Ed to record this
conversation with his
phone
fore
spee
[Music]
Jean Paul Miguel then traveled to Madrid
R for this mystery meeting the person
meeting him was the head of internal
affairs of the national Spanish police
Martin blast this is sworn courtroom
testimony of what happened in this
[Music]
meeting
for
the uh investigation led by uh the
Spanish government in uh Andora trying
to find the personal accounts of uh
president
puol uh my accounts and the vice
president R junas in my case uh well
they failed because there were no
accounts in Andora although they thought
that uh they were there but they weren't
he said that we do not have them as a
clients except P but he could not give
any information because this was not
legal and he could not well then if you
do not
do accept the
consequences this is a coordinated work
between Spanish
police and the treasury Department at
least at least I mean
there's no doubt about that
because one highest rank officer of the
war Civil in
Spain when into TV saying
this
so they they even themselves they
admitting what they did
also this man Jose Manuel viero the
former commissioner for the Spanish
police was also hired to help frame BPA
Vio is a very Spanish character I mean
he has been very high and now is sitting
in a Cell in a prison but Vio is a key
person alongside with other policemen in
what was called catalunia operation
Operation catalunia which is very much
related with the blockage and the
destroying of BPA but when I'm saying
very high he was working for the
government he was a police officer but
also a private entrepreneur he
intermediated in a lot of complicate
situations and when I say complicated
situation people that were journalist
kidnapped in Syria by terrorist groups
and things like that but he was making
money out of everything while he was a
civil servant and he has admitted
several things one of those is that he
lied in order to destroy
BPA where are the consequence until now
we haven't seen it I mean he got such an
amount of information that he talks
properly seriously clearly with all the
evidence on the
table in Spain some people will have big
big troubles even though the ruling
government of andur is comprehensively
aware that BPA was framed by Spain and
tricked the US Treasury by presenting
fake evidence thus fully aware of the
Innocence of the managers of BPA
andora's prosecutors are still trying to
imprison bpa's top managers for money
laundering this fake criminal case
continues into 2020 5 years years after
America's section 311 this is something
unbelievable the first thinking is that
you cannot believe it when you wake up
every morning you say Well it must be
something wrong I I I have not wake up I
must still be dreaming because this is
not real but when you finally see that
it is real then comes a situation in
which a depression faces in because you
you you cannot accept that and it uh
threats all your parts of your life your
family and uh as I feel a lot of
companions which are in the same
position a lot of them for which I put
my hand on the fire
and it's impossible that the things that
we are being accused of our truth I have
a lot of angry in myself I I know that
it's not good and it's not healthy but I
really do I cannot avoid that I came to
Andora to work at PPA in fact so I have
been living here for more than 20 years
I'm Andor now first I was Spanish and I
I feel really really bad I get the
passport the andoran passport because my
children are andoran my husband is
andoran and I want to be all in the in
the same country but if it's not for
that I I
will I will not get the the andoran
passport
because I feel really betrayed really
betrayed I feel really betrayed from the
supervisor from the Justice from
everywhere because I have been in a lot
of meetings with the supervisor telling
that we are doing things right that we
are working good with the colleagues of
other Banks saying that okay Isel please
explain me how you do this okay oh
that's a good idea let's make this let's
talk about this and at least they say
that we are money Landers we were
working together because we were very
interested in in avoid money lering with
the police I have called the police a
lot of times and we have always helping
them because we thought that we are on
the on the right side I mean the
reputational damage has been so
big that I I am an employer as I said I
mean no no company will hire
me at all because their reputation risk
is very high for that company and if
even if you want to start a business you
will find your yourself that you will
need to get a bank account for that
business and it will be very hard to do
that I have a still block all the money
in an in BPA you have no access to that
money no but not only
this I went to all the banks from
Andora to open an
account and no one opened me an
account I leave from my wife
how much money is missing in BPA do we
know how much from from the customers of
BPA from the uh the owners uh in
everything all maybe 1 billion one more
than 1 billion would would you say this
was like a clever bank robbery would you
call it that I have this
feeling what do you think would happen
if someone decided to allow everyone who
had money in BPA to have their money
back what do you think would happen
there's not enough money at all at all
there is not enough money if someone the
justice will ask to to redo everything
and everybody get the money back from
BPA is not possible because there will
not be enough money to to get back to
the
customers which is precisely why the dor
justice system needs a guilty verdict
Andor has even gone so far as to publish
the names of everyone from BPA facing
prison on the front page of its largest
newspaper advertising how long they will
spend in prison and how much they will
be paying in fines when found guilty
Jean Paul 8 years in prison € 100
million EUR in fines Santiago 8 years in
prison €70 million EUR in fines Isabel 7
years in prison $70 million e in fines
Joan 6 years in prison €70 million EUR
Pablo 6 years in prison 70 million EUR
you are guilty before
trial and because you are guilty before
trial um in in front of the public
opinion the state has the permission has
a load to do all that state things
necessary to stop you to prevent your
succe success
not only low fair but also media
fair to make matters more absurd while
Andora is busy trying to place its own
innocent citizens in prison the andoran
government is simultaneously filing
lawsuits against Spain for extorting and
framing BPA for money
laundering
I could not get a single member of the
andoran government to speak to me on
camera about this story with the
exception of the head of the andoran
institute for human
rights
you start with a Vincent note which is a
little butterfly and on the other side
of the world you have a hurricane some
months later and this is what happened a
little letter with no support very small
move itself a bit and on the other side
of the Atlantic was a proper hurricane
that devastate a bank families lawyers
and a lot of people I I I mean here it's
not just a a matter of money I mean when
people are
indicted they're under scrutiny they
have a social problem don't forget that
andur is a very little country they were
highly respect people and now they're
treated like
criminals but not only the the owners
and the managers of vpa but
also something very important the
lawyers and why the lawyers are
important because we are the last line
of defense for many people and if you
are criminalized everybody could be
criminalized and and at the end of the
day you see families destroyed credibil
is destroyed uh a huge
cost in defense uh and people who don't
know where they will be in a year's time
and this case is already 5 years going
on and they don't know when it's going
to come to an end which will be the
result because look it's very simple if
you shoot somebody you know more the
less which will be the
result but if you haven't shoot
anybody and you are in a process for
shooting somebody you didn't shoot the
result could be anything so the
uncertainty is tremendous and the impact
in their lives and in their feelings and
their families and their kids because
all of them got kids uh is tremendous
and this is part of the
devastation of a hurricane created with
a small butterfly on the other side of
the Atlantic do you think this will ever
be resolved this BBA case do you
anything you want to say just well uh I
I I think really you cannot resolve the
effects of the hurricane without
resolving what has caused it and that is
not here it's not in andur it's in the
US remember Jennifer Calvary the
director of finsen she not only
authorized the section 311 against BPA
but she is also the one who negotiated
hsbc's $1.9 billion fine for laundering
money for the caloa drug cartel guess
where she is today Jennifer Shi Calvary
who is global head for financial crime
threat mitigation at
HSBC remember Jordi cinka the blood
diamond Smuggler who later became
andor's Finance Minister and how he
commissioned America's price Waterhouse
Coopers to perform the BPA customers
audit 6 days after America's section 311
in September 2019 Mr CA was to be tapped
as the new director of an andoran branch
of price waterhous Coopers but his
position was aborted due to a serious
reputational problem however in January
2020 Jordi CA was appointed head of
andora's retirement Reserve fund endor's
Social Security Administration
responsible for securing the Endor and
citizen their retirement
[Music]
money while the majority of President
Carles pu deon's cabinet still sits in a
Spanish prison in January 2020 the
European Union headquartered in Belgium
has granted president caros puon a seat
at the European Union Carlos puon began
his mandate as me in Strasburg amid
great media expectation before attending
the plenary session he called on Europe
for action and said Catalonia is no
longer an internal Spanish affair so we
are here in order to remember and to
claim to to European Union institution
to be involved in a solution based on
dialogue Mr Gonzalo Boer is also
president pu deon's attorney I
interviewed Mr Boer in August of 2019
when he proclaimed this statement sooner
than later they will try to indict us
for whatever money laundering or
whatever they will invent it and they
will try it because at the end it's not
a matter of result it a it's a matter of
destroying the person and 8 weeks later
this
[Music]
happened anyone with money in the uran
banking system should consider three
problems the first is that it has a
fractional Reserve banking system but no
Central Bank there's therefore no one to
act as lender of Last Resort the second
problem is that andur uses the Euro as a
currency but is not in fact a member of
either the European Union nor the Euro
Zone it therefore has no access to the
European Central Bank and more
importantly it has no method of printing
Euros in order to provide the banks with
liquidity and finally it has a third
problem Deposit Insurance Andora has
this up to €100,000 per account but that
lack of a central bank and that lack of
a way to print Euros means that their
insurance isn't really all that much
good andora's annual budget is only 470
million e while andor's Banks
collectively manage more than 49 billion
e which is more than 100 times that of
andor's annual budget andor's annual
budget doesn't cover half of what is
supposedly Frozen in
BPA sorry it's okay no no we
start look you have
[Music]
to to have this money from Andora
because I believe that they are going to
disappear
[Music]
yes